[Musica]
[Applauso]
come chi sente la tensione di pancia è
una cosa che ti spinge avanti
la cosa che ti inibisce la senti perché
ogni tanto ti fa un po di confusione e
un paura io ho cominciato con questo
sogno come piccola volevo lavorare per
la nasa non solo per la nasa però
lavorare su marte ho incontrato un paio
di dubbi però sono riuscita
era lì però marte non era disponibile
ho dovuto cominciare con i pianeti e un
po più lontani
giove nettuno urlano il mio compito è di
fare una mappa perché è il primo sondhi
spaziale che è arrivato cercare la sera
la maniero sfera economico lambo quando
colombe è andata a scoprire l'america
anche lui avevamo una mappa ok quindi ho
cominciato con un po di matematica un po
di cene so sono riuscita a non sai
perché non può capire bene mi sono messa
dentro i dati e quando li sentiva un po
lontano di casa poi a matera e che
scherzo mezzo i cordonati della sera ho
visto lo ingrandito ancora e ancora
niente lo colorato blu lam pancia andò
finalmente la
e mi ha toccato quanto siamo piccoli ma
ti rendi conto con 100 milioni di galaxy
e quanto siamo piccoli non potevo più
lavorare
ho dovuto scappare non so o scappato
dall'ufficio sono uscito cercare un gol
cross e se sì ci sono che patera pete
ripetere ci siamo ci siamo ok che possa
spiegare che tipo di vergogna queste
essere uno chi vuole studiare lo spazio
che poi abbia paura dello spazio che
fragogna ma sono l'unica qua che a
questa paura e dentro un meeting
finalmente ho tutto spiegare questa
modello davanti tutti scienziati ho
detto ap si fa il bagno
però non ho dovuto andare in bagno ho
dovuto scappare cercare il mio labbro
carlo come faccio come vado avanti con
gelato quindi ancora in cui ho dovuto
rubare ma anche credenza e dietro questa
paura la mia insignificanza il mio
piccolo magari davanti tutti questi
scienziati non sono riuscita a proprio
capire che donna potevo fare agli schemi
e ho cercato a capire che magari sono
l'unica certamente l'unica donna però
l'unica nel mondo che chi sono io e
cerco di fare sempre il mio meglio
ok finalmente il sogno spaziale è
arrivato a turno e
quando è arrivato tutti questi dati sono
sono tornate tutto storto tutto store da
niente
non abbiamo capito che cosa è successo
sono i dati sono arrivati bene e modello
ma dalla nostra si guarda questi dati
non mi sembra che sia una di questi
pianeti che va con la bella ballerina
che fa attorno e solenne o questo questo
questo pianeta fa capriole e tutti cosa
è affrontato queste credenze collettivo
ma che ovviamente chi fa capire ma si si
si
non è un altro mondo magari potrebbe
essere e si finalmente si urlano fa
capirò les voix finalmente sono tornate
a marte quando dovuto guardare questi
pianeti così lontana quasi a casa marte
meno male abbiamo fatto il primo
prototipo per andare su marte ma che
meraviglia wow
7 giorni su marte con questo robot e sai
una cosa interessante che per questo
robot il primo progetto di fattibilità e
di vedere se questo un robot avere un
istinto con paura
il rogo ha potuto navigare marte cercare
un un sasso qua un sasso qua e senza
fallire e si meno male è andato non
sette giorni 85 giorni però questo non è
la meraviglia lame vedi le
era il proprio capire a quel punto
quanto noi siamo una mia regia perché
sai con intelligenza artificiale è molto
facile è molto più facile a meno di
creare un esperto tra molto più
difficile di creare un bambino curiosità
e le ville i tassi ancora sono le cose
più difficili da costruire noi il nostro
fiamma finalmente ho avuto anch'io dei
bambini che bello stare accanto a loro
pagare il mondo i loro occhi a vedere
tutto quello che ti viene fuori ha però
un giorno il mio primo film stava
infatti è nato inospitale da tutto a
posto a un disastro non capivo prova
bene i medici ci sono che ci sono sono
accanto sono accanto però non potevano
aiutarlo rete stessa
sai sono diventato di nuovo un killer
senza poter andar lo è avvenuto tutto
questo paura tutto questo sa dove
comincio finalmente il mio bambino mi ha
guardato gli occhi
mamma mamma o caduto in un buio immenso
o in solitudine
più immenso che tutti questi centri
bisogno di galleria non è una macchina
magari atkinson di spaziare il mio
figlio quindi paure che ho avuto il mio
piccolissimo non potevo portare dovuto
andare a cercare la risposta per lui mi
sono mese non so quanti tipo di articoli
di guardare questa malattia da rubato
ricci a neurologia
ma che cos'è che cos'è alla fine è
questo buio
penso che proprio in quel momento quando
nessuno ci ascolta quando deve
ridefinire tu ti regoli quali deve
affrontare un qualcosa di questo genere
in quel buio in quella solitudine e
quando esce la fiaba intero proprio
l'intuizione si perché non c'è nessun
altro aiuto sei tu li contatti con la
candella a cercare la risposta sì beh
con questa ipotesi e ho trovato un'idea
è l'unica cosa a dipanare starete cocco
però per questo bambino progretto il
dato è andato oltre
non ho toccato il suo è andato il suo
cervello quindi passava poco a quel
punto ho dovuto affrontare tutta la
situazione medica ma lei chi sei ma
amano incrociata
qualcosa semplicità e andiamo a cosa
molto difficile
devo dire chiaro infine con un
antibiotico semplice è guarito mio
figlio atro giorni
poi non so quanti bambini soffrono
quanti bambini top che ci siamo tornati
a casa ho sentito questi orly consiglio
alle 4 della mattina e magari ci sono
altri bambini
infatti io ho messo in piedi una
conferenza medica cercando di magari
invitare i cuochi dottori dalle novità
vi è però no sono venuti genti da 23
paesi e rai per china è stato un fulmine
di di bambini non sono dico a bra ov
unque e abbiamo mese per i tantissimi
cosi abbiamo salvato i tantissimi
bambini e sono con una prospettiva sa i
[Musica]
tanti cosi succede nella nostra vita c'è
sempre quella spinto quelle sensazioni
di pancia che ti porta avanti
disperazione o l'istinto di proteggersi
ma non siamo un robot di marte abbiamo
il nostro fiamma la cosa molto
importante e di abbracciare la paura di
emulare guardare che credenza c'è perché
si magari c'è sempre la credenza
collettivo che il dobbiamo abbattere
però l'urp la credenze noi stessi questa
mafia ma che dobbiamo portare avanti e
quindi chiedo
non chiedere perché chiedere perché no
grazie
[Applauso]